dans la forêt des hautes côtes de nuits
au dessus du village d'arcenant il
existe un endroit jonché d'imposants
monticule de pierre peut-être dix et on
les ruines d'un château
daniel ratte elle a participé aux
fouilles archéologiques qui ont mis au
jour un site gallo romain de 12 hectares
situé à la croisée des routes
commerciales de l'antiquité en orange
vous avez les routes qui est lente et
utiliser l'époque gallo-romaine deuxième
siècle principalement et vont vers vous
avez une route plus anciennes qui est
d'avant l'occupation gallo-romaine qui
était déjà utilisé cinq siècles avant
l'occupation khallouf gallo-romaine et
qui permettait d'aller chercher les
teints en angleterre et de sites
il est là entre l'ancien et le nouvel
itinéraire le plus court chemin en ligne
droite entre la saône et la seine mais
avec un relief épuisant en montée pour
les attelages au point le plus haut dans
ce lieu aujourd'hui enfouie sous les
arbres
il trouvait une halte où se restaurer
boire et honorer les dieux du commerce
et du voyage le chemin principal passait
du bas de ces constructions l'a donc
devant lendemain des seuils des portes
chaque fois que le mur est un peu plus
basse et l entrée et là on a des locaux
commerciaux quatre boutiques en enfilade
seules les parties basses des murs sont
restés debout ici on achetait des
offrandes a déposées au temple
un boulanger faisait cuire du pain voici
les vestiges du four qui pouvait
ressembler à celui ci découvert sur un
autre site en alsace un peu plus bas le
chemin débouche sur ce qui a été une
ferme avec ses dépendances
les charrettes venait jusque là en
témoignent ces grosses pierres
des chasses rouge de chaque côté de
l'entrée je m'en étais complètement
empiré mais pas en grandes dalles la
romaine il était en petits galets bleus
voilà il faut imaginer ici une
habitation de 7 à 8 mètres de hauteur
avec un étage à l'arrière du bâtiment
voué aux activités agricoles
les archéologues ont découvert des
graines de l'orge du blé des lentilles
re torréfié par un incendie
c'est l'inra de montpellier qui a
conduit les études et qui nous a permis
de dire aussi comment ces graines
étaient cultivées en mélange sur le
plateau donc de savoir que c'est un
grand découvert au soleil sur les 10
hectares de cultures là sont les
informations des laboratoires à une
trentaine de mètres de la ferme
le temple gallo-romain est juste à côté
un lieu de culte primitif un emplacement
choisi par les celtes pour la nature de
la roche sous sol du calcaire de limit
is et nous sommes dignes de locre jaune
la couleur du soleil
pour eux la couleur des dieux on a là la
tradition celtique où on enferme pas le
dieu sait qu une plateforme où discutent
avec les dieux à travers les feuillages
sur une plate-forme en matériaux bruts
alors que là on à l'adoption des
techniques romaine gallo romaine avec
une c'est là au milieu une tour où le
dieu loges et autour un déambulatoire
pour faire justement les circonvolutions
dans le sens du soleil à proximité du
temple un bassin de 4 mètres de diamètre
pouvait contenir jusqu'à 12 mètres cubes
d'eau de source
filtrés par du charbon de bois les
archéologues se sont interrogés sur ce
qui semblait être une margelle depuis
c'est en fait la délimitation d'un
endroit où il fallait éviter de marché
devenu sacré après avoir été frappé par
la foudre comme la foudre est tombée sur
le sanctuaire pour les occupants ça
voulait dire que les dieux ne voulait
plus qu'il soit là
c'est la raison sans doute pour laquelle
les lieux ont été définitivement
abandonnée aux alentours de l'an 273